Marianne Williamson has no experience
relevant to being president of the
United States if you tell me hey you
know what David we have too many like
lawyers
who are presidents or business people
who are President we need people from
different backgrounds
I'm with you I want scientists as
presidents I want you know people who
have led non-profits would be great for
presidents uh I would like to see people
from the field of Education be present
there's oh I'm with you we have two
narrow a scope for people that
eventually become president but Marianne
Williamson has no relevant experience no
relevant expertise no qualifications and
also none of the relationships that
would make you a more effective
president she's for Medicare for all
that's great
she believes climate change should be
taken seriously great but she's not
going to push Biden to the left